hello it's your cool dad Adam Silver
welcome to the Eastern face of playoff
Mountain each team will Traverse their
own path finding opponents on their way
to the summit where the champion will
take on the best of the western base
please make your way to your assigned
path hell yeah I'm hyped let's go
chill bro the strongest Heroes of the
East Lands are all here
on your mark get set oh
slow down if we get lost I'm gonna get
blamed and sent away relax I was brought
here to guide you I think we need to go
oh
maybe we should turn around Paul George
writes that everywhere let's find our
first opponent
good fight
looks like we gotta Buy
uh
uh guys
looks like the only thing stopping us
from playoff success
is ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
all right here's what we do I take out
all three
Julius slow down the pace that's the
same speed move unnecessary
the shadow Nicks have all our moves
including our flaws which means Shadow
RJ shouldn't be able to shoot from there
hey not true
[Music]
careful spikes
that finally breaks me
every year
too far
yes and the same height as Donovan
Mitchell
you dare to defeat us
and anyone else
so much pressure I'm out
predictable
snakes
oh Julius
[Applause]
looks like you're playing worked
all we needed was some heart sorry
ah it's just the Knicks this should be
an easy fight trust us it's harder than
you think
who will reach the top of player of
mountains and lay claim to the new face
of the league well if I know I just know
they get paid a hell lot more than what
I was a hero also my playoff prediction
Wizards at the great Bradley Bill win it
all shut up Chuck I'm trying to wrap up
the season
my endorsements
[Music]
oh